okay welcome back guys in just about two
minutes the Revit chess tournament is
starting gonna be two hours of let's
Jess five plus zero and I'm already
debating whether or not like berserk
most of my games I'm not sure if I'm
playing to win the tournament or if I'm
just playing
to play good games I mean ideally both
so I'll probably have some threshold
like the zerk against any player below
2000 seems like a lot of player is like
over 200 so far hello JH SK the first
commenter in the chats welcome just
about a minute left I have no idea who
this guy is
this town title player rated 2607 seems
like dangerous person I probably play
him first round two maybe I should start
preparing but he's not online I wonder
if people like join the tournament so it
was announced like a few weeks ago like
they joined the tournament and then they
forgot about it
I mean close switch tabs here a lot of
games ideally I would like to access his
insights just to see what openings he
plays but I'm going through old Benoni
is black okay to play a London okay let
me close all my other tabs and we'll
just focus on this
I could get a a forfeit in round one
we'll see a little bit of lag oh I'm not
playing him I'm playing someone who's
below me I'm a singer with a sub thanks
I'm singer seven months in a row there's
a lot of lag here what's going on okay
at least it splits then go for this line
with H for c6 I think is playable but
still going for h4 h5 and this will be
an interesting position to play Queen h2
here let me play let me play 95 first
I'd have six Queen h2 and then 95 I'm
gonna try and keep up the pace queenside
castle
I mean objectively a box should be fine
but practically this is very playable
I'm gonna play f3g for 97 decent move g4
so have any merits
I wouldn't like to trade in plane 93 I
still want to do this pawn push and I'm
okay if he takes I'm not accepting
challenges I'm playing the reddit chess
arena it's a two-hour long tournaments
and it just started so whoever is
watching you're just on time I've ideas
a Bishop c7 let's play off three it's
always played f3 and g4 will come my
knight will probably return to e5 Wow
okay let's play 95 maybe e4 will come ok
he wants to I mean we could just take an
early draw but I want to win
before we trade stuff let's do it
I want to get a position where his King
has no safe place so the center opens up
I would be ideal I mean we could end up
trading a lot of things if I take on g4
and play Queen g3 get the bishop pair I
have two Center pawns he 500 he wants to
play nine h5
so maybe Bishop e5 but then still 9 h5
so maybe Queen III just solid move ha
still Knight h5 though Bishop h6 is a
annoying move so always picking me 1 he
doesn't take the bishop my bishop has no
great place to go unless I want to move
to h2 me just Bishop c4 let's develop
completed with development
maybe soon I want to play D 585 re 5
let's play d5 because I want to kill his
Bishop I'm telling the exchange so I
have to close things down a little bit
if he doesn't take then I'll probably
and I'd probably go for a Bishop h2 soon
and pawns are actually equal finally I
want to pawn know how I lost the pawn
back so Bishop h2
he's kicking you around not the most
pleasant situation
I mean if g3 Bishop g1 we so have some
small time advantage
now I want to go for d5 when it works
nice for maybe work f1 that's a pin
threatening some kind of Bishop d3 or
Bishop e3 whoo he's pinning me back
kind of a four maybe you play a four
King needs some lift not so comfortable
I mean he has a lot of Kings side play
but I'm holding on decent Center Bishop
d3 let's play this game space
Queen III is an idea because as bishops
kind of stuck maybe I should have played
that sooner
maybe I have a t5 ideas d5 taketake gets
messy so Bishop t3 looks normal maybe 94
to d6 he's gonna play Bishop f4 yeah d6
is a nice hole I mean he might be ready
to sack so I could start with like queen
bee for the queen bee for an a6 will
come in combination
I have a huge time advantage 96 looks
fun he opened up this rank for the Queen
I can take on pissant right
tick that's weird
okay let's play in 96
maybe Bishop asics will come
feels very close to winning I don't see
the knockout blow
I want to play d5 maybe queen c5 first
cuz I stuck this batteries nice I have
full control just have to keep up the
pace yeah I was calculating Knight G 3 D
5 because now I'm threatening made in 1
he'll probably play b6 I take on c6 with
a queen he takes on d6 I take back with
pawn he takes this is just oh that's not
mean one
what's going on
Queen take B seven in 97 as possible
Knight a p7 should get the job done so
I'm tightening Knight c5 check with
Queens 87 so he has no time to take the
rook and his King can't escape either if
Kings yet I have Queen Queen EA king
queen b8
okay this is looking nice now I'm up
exchange in his Kings on c5
there should be two with such a funny
position mr. B 2 will come and my a pawn
will Queen to Queens races two minor
pieces okay that was nice interesting
game that start was Bishop e6 mate did I
miss made than one this should be six I
think he had King take d6 Amber's irking
this guy will have a four Knights Bishop
c5 and d5 will come
he's giving me a nice center usually
night take d5s not a great move but okay
it's playable it's white Bishop g4 black
will have a slight advantage keep the
pressure I want to play rook d8 and E
for you really wants to trade so avoid
trading still want to play e4 thanks for
the bits toilet noggin welcome back I
was watching some of your games earlier
it's pretty intense bullet I could play
this if Bishop take b7 I have rook b8
rook take p2 and then C 2 will fall
and in the meantime I just want to play
h6 remove midnight and then take on f3
with check double with his pawns bullet
is difficult
I felt really bad at bullet yesterday I
was playing near jet ski and he just
adopted me he we play like a 30 game
match and the final score was like he
scored over 25 points and I scored less
than 5 I like this position there's
multiple threats mites under a lot of
pressure I have to play every game with
the assumption that my opponents are
watching so I might have to hold back
and what the best move might be for
whites but I'm looking at this position
it's hard to find like a good response
for white to cover everything
yeah I don't know what the exact score
was I feel like I scored three and a
half points out of a lot of games okay
h6 will come now I want to take on f3
he's gonna play 94 probably take with
check and then retreat the Queen
actually this is a funny move on
threatening a 2 and I'm threatening
Bishop take e4 Queen take e4 with the
pin I'd be okay simplifying into a some
kind of endgame I'm also threatening f5
which might be even stronger Knight c3
Queen Jake f3
and the time is just about equal yeah
five Humanzee five but I mean I could
take a two as well let's take a two
safer remove and I'll probably drop back
to e6 or not okay to dance around
Queenie six will come by five first but
fi first the maybe Queen D six whoa and
I take these sevens of threats good move
I might be threatening b6 and I has to
go back to a4 so rook take E 5 oh he's
finding this oh I'm giving him chances
okay I think this is okay if he plays 96
I have rook f e8 I was trying to be
solid but I loosened the grip a little
bit
I mean okay I'm up up two pawns now I'm
up one pot one pawn still a lot he's
thinking always a good sign toilet
noggin is off okay see you later toilet
noggin I'm happy to trade Queens he
might be happy to but that would make
both of us happy I forgot about b7 but
it's okay
9650 794 bishop f7 ooh
now his night is kind of stuck this is
threatening to win material I don't know
if he can let's get maybe rookie to or
that let's play c6 I just want to trap
the Knights okay now let's just win upon
interesting
should be a relatively easy win
okay how's the fights I am in 14th place
maybe I can break 2400 the first place
has I'm not accepting challenges so
please don't challenge me who's in first
place
Wow ten points was working every year
it's a challenge with this is in order
to place highly probably have to berserk
oh I wanted to play e4 no Carlsen played
this once let's play that's an
aggressive opening I can play with III
I'll play this line with b3 Bishop f5 I
mean I teach for at some points we have
actually over versus London
so I'm trying to figure out how the
extra tempo is useful for whites I'll
probably play a bishop you saw who okay
that's probably helpful for me now I
have slightly more Center now the plan
is queenie to e4 if he wants to stop
before he has to play 94 and i'm happy
to trade
I am a GM welcome back yeah the collie
is not the most aggressive opening ever
unfortunately I could have played like a
reverse England
- III d5 and then II for would have been
aggressive
okay I'm gonna prevent mm no I don't
have to prevent you five if you play z5
I wouldn't material I still want to play
you for is he gonna play you five if he
doesn't play you five I play you five
it's kind of a win-win situation only
thing that doesn't win is my bishop okay
now everything wins promises Queen on d8
so if Bishop takes five just Queen takes
Yeates
rook take two you I take you five or
even Bishop to g5 night a key five I
defend the Queen you're all win the
Knights and then I'll play rugby one who
can I be tricky that's what of this so
if you takes I have rook e1
okay now I'll prevent ninety-seven don't
bring my Knight to d6
you know the challenge is gonna be
winning games quickly as even with
buzzer King games can still last a good
deal of time in some positions like this
point we'll just resign
this guy's gonna fight so have to be
accurate like okay rook ft-1 maybe
Brooks you 7 then rook td7
or maybe even rook c1 I don't know let's
play rook c7 first you hope I can be
paired with King crusher is he also he's
also flying was in third place to catch
up to him 96 let's play h4 just so I
don't blend her back rank it's 96 rook
t8
okay we'll trade you put the bishop on
III
I just want to make a pass pawn would be
nice I want to win age six yes it's mine
I kidding okay my nights not getting
trapped which is good
defend the bishop maybe I can trap his
knights just win another pond boo maybe
I can mate without needing to Queen hey
it's a sub and I won so many good things
happening at once
so I'm number six ten points leader has
15 yeah the key is to berserk
yeah thank you cron double-oh-seven
twitch Prime I'm not taking challenges
I'm sorry maybe after the tournament
though but if you want to play me
hold off on challenging until after the
tournament okay so now I'm playing I'm
playing a lot of lower rate of players
just not a bad thing let's play pawns
eonni
mmm Bishop c5 only makes d4 stronger
okay that's a free piece let's play
maybe e5 look Knight c3 let's develop
Bishop g5 interesting
let's just take if he takes with Queen
oh he's sitting d4 why am i struggling
here
I could take here will just simplify
everything I should be up a rook in the
end if he takes on d4 sigh castling
winning the bishop
we may be Bishop e2 and always play King
b1 interesting just preparing rook c1
okay let's play e5 I want to make a pass
pawn as quickly as possible
like g4 he wants a draw I don't know
draw
let's just play Bishop c6 and meet him
is he gonna find b5 ah he found it
I shouldn't have told him I still want
to meet him before and then moving the
bishop will be mates there we go okay a
second place helps to play a lower rate
of players very secret cactus I like how
his username is like a reddit user name
with the you underscore he's taking some
time because he's loading up my stream
he wants to hear my thoughts so I have
to be careful I'm gonna play a Budapest
what tourney is this this is a reddit
chess arena there's a subreddit for
chess and it was a noun stand organized
through people there let's play this
sneaky move threatening this or this
I have bishop take III I may have had
bishop take III at some points hmm okay
let's play a four but he wants to play
f4 that's okay I dare him to play off
for he's probably listening in to so now
he's trying to figure out if at four is
a good move or a bad move he doesn't
play it's a queen g6 maybe I have to
move much quicker let's play rock a6 I'm
not hiding my intentions 94 interesting
he forked me but I pin him
now g2s attacked too
I also had bishop before Chuck there
it's also playable so now maybe d5
followed by Bishop take h3 white should
be in trouble as I have a King side
attack and this is hard to defend
if g3 what's my threats maybe just 97
trying to figure this out I'm defending
the bishop and attacking the Knights I
completely forgot about the rook but I
can wait if I take the knight whoa
what's going on well I forgot to berserk
that's good I thought my desserts I
forgot to berserk
so I have time to think here okay Brooke
take e4
I think rook to e4 is actually working
unless he has Bishop d3
but I have Bishop to e3
this is getting really crazy Oh know
what's going on just hope it works
because I have the threats
I could lose us not sure what's going on
here
and he could lose us too
yeah I think he should have taken the
rook but this is maybe also playable I
have work h4 here that should just be
crushing cuz he has no counter play I'm
gonna move my Bishop f1 regardless of
whether he moves his rook or not I'm
queen h2 will prolong the game but
actually it's probably just Force mates
I think I think I would have been in
trouble if he took the rook rather than
taking on III because Bishop Bishop
takes e4 okay I wanted to show but can't
waste any time
so where's the horse mates this is force
mates
so yeah Bishop takes e4 Queen take g3
King h1 I was gonna play Queen h4 then
he can take o the cream of didn't
register after I move backwards
interesting okay dr. tournament I forgot
to berserk so Wow born of good and void
buzzer King and winning everything 2572
okay I have to be careful you just
started a game so I won't play him I
have to berserk
to keep up I'm on the verge of breaking
2400 just need a few more wins so it's
been just over half hour which means I'm
playing Sophie don't forget to beserk
and play e4
I have asked Angie let's play this
we'll have some kind of exchange French
or I'm I'll just play an IQ p position
yeah I haven't had a 2000 plus opponent
since the first round the first round I
played an FM but since then I've been
playing much lower rated players this is
okay
I assume this is okay I hope it's okay
he takes on c4 I have d5 or if she takes
on c4 to make assumptions here otherwise
like if Bishop d6 maybe c5 hmm in the
meantime I just want to castle
Wow Queen d7 so doc might want to Castle
queenside mmm Bishop g5 in Bishop g5
lots of pressure
because d5 is a main focus now I can
play defy myself and there's some idea
of playing Queen d4 soon
like right now I'm hitting this I'm
hitting four different things and I'm
not scared at all about night c2 or
maybe I am but I don't want her to know
that no this is this is trouble for
black Wow or is it if I take on c6 Queen
284 I take tea for Brooke take tea for
take on b7 can take b7 but should take
f6 take take ok let me just take on c4
simple move no need to calculate those
crazy lines
I'll take care 95 I have an idea though
but does it work I take here because I
want to play rook t1 it's probably a bad
idea though yeah I was terrible
I made some assumption the assumption
did not was not a good assumption
I have to move quickly to
let's do this
go for some attack I'm below a minute
not good
nice this is a threats
I've [ __ ] about for ideas maybe at some
points
okay so I'm down upon Queens are
probably gonna get traded I'll still
have comp it's still some attack to
I want to play b6
I'm losing connection what's going on I
mean this is looking more fun now but
the time situation is not fun wait I
just dropped a queen oh my gosh okay I
have to uh I'm gonna try and fight but
it's harder to fight when I'm down a
queen how did that happen I forgot my
bishop was defending the Queen so
focused on attacking this is really bad
I'll be seven is a target but time
situation not so good
I'm just down a full/queen and the pawn
but maybe she's nervous scary threats my
box taking a lot of time here that's
good let's play this I just want to win
the Queen back
I won the Queen back let's play this Oh
such a nice gift I have a mating attack
what is going on okay
I have hope lots of hope
thanks for the bits whoever you are that
was a terrible move
but I'm up on time but there's lag
okay I feel so bad about that but I also
feel really good about that
I didn't lose I'm in second place I
dropped a queen how I dropped the Queen
I was yeah the definition of a dirty
flag and you can't fault you can't spell
a flag without lag there's a lot of lag
there well I had a rule before the
tournament I'm not gonna beserk against
a player above 2,000 so I'm happy to
play a reversed London very fine with
this let's play a c4 or c5 Bishop g6 get
some interesting setup c3 what a move
maybe e5m Castle queenside make it a
maker the shark game and everything
could just close down in 97 I want to
play this for some night to make a
decision because of the H file opens I'm
happy okay
Bishop f3 could be strong at 5 weird
position when the goal is not to blend
you're a queen like last game
efore maybe this move I want to play g4
I plundered it Bishop what's going on
I'm so out of form we're gonna fight
though I mean I have some counterplay
kind of not really g5 maybe
Wow what Queen could get stuck
what to do queen maybe Queen c7 followed
by rookie - I'll play rookie - in them
95 Wow f4 still rookie - or g3 maybe
let's play g3 rookie to play rookie -
first and then maybe g3
okay this is getting crazy and I have
work take g2 in Quincy six but Queen g5
is annoying
crazy positions g3 wants to play g7
which is very strong threats complete
Queen G queen c6 right away it's looking
decent work f2
ork take F to work H to
I have a crazy idea I might just work
I'm all sacrificing I'm gonna do it oh
he doesn't take okay or he doesn't push
let's do this
okay have to play quick and aggressively
ah that doesn't work the Queen's on that
five
yeah I think I was just being too
hopeful let's do this
still putting up a fight time is just
about equal but I'm still up on time too
Wow interesting move
I don't think I'm gonna dirty flag this
game I'm just trying to find safety that
was rough the first loss of the
tournament
no he played while I hung a piece almost
got some attack but not quite I really
wanted to do this this rook h1 Queen h6
idea that never worked out so I'm gonna
have to fight on top Sakai has not lost
looks like one draw kind of the berserk
and me play a different opening play it
with a three Bishop d6 suspicious just
looks weird just gonna play normal chess
maybe a Bishop g5
mmm because he's Castle he doesn't want
to play g5 maybe I'll Castle queenside
and go for like h3 g4
hmm okay I have to take like d5 why not
and Feingold what is with all these been
final emotes okay
maybe g4g for looks nice
it's way G for no let's not play G for
I'll keep my Knights did been fine would
like host what's going on or people are
just a fan of 10 there should be three
at some point I'll probably play a G for
allowing on f4 and go for g5 but the
rook on g1
h4 h5 o cuz I said suspicious ah now I
get it
okay all makes sense now always play
King v1 I'm not gonna play King v1 I
might regret it but it's not time for
quiet moves
I did play knife i-5 though anyone have
the knife at five emotes we'd have to
subscribe to bed as a tier 3
um it's kind of annoying Bishop c4 or
just g5 maybe just g5
well I sac a piece if he takes on b3
nevermind
actually don't know what to do here
yeah I guess I don't have any
and he immediate advantage he's gonna
play g6 and then we'll trade I'll go for
d4 at some points d4 maybe now
I rec should be ie1
a lot of tension in the center mmm let's
do this first I'm keeping all the
tension
I want to play 95
one of the goals be six good move
I played Knight d5 probably not but
maybe wow I have to move much quicker I
forgot about time again I think this is
working though if he takes with night I
have Queen c4 I went back the piece I
just can't flag
ooh I should have played King b1 okay
King dy I guess I forgot about Queen a
to work h3 this was very unpleasant
I really should've played king v1
it's a bit nerve-wracking waiting for
him to move interesting
see another dirty flag maybe
I feel so bad but not really I'm in
fourth place playing someone new
this is guys actual reading I'm not
gonna buzzer let's play a London f5 I'll
still play the London as long as c5 is
interesting it's one recommendation
against the Dutch maybe provoke d5 play
h4 mmm McQueen maybe night here first
I just want to provoke d5 he's not
playing it
I play d5 myself in 95
wait Queen b3 might work Queen b3 let's
play Queen b3 I'm not scared of 95 even
though I should maybe should be okay
because now it's kind of the structure
is determined it's a good move
now he's playing well the Bishop e5
doesn't look great
but maybe necessary I'm already in
trouble
queenside castle maybe that's good thing
I didn't desert this game
Wow first place has 49 points 527 okay
I'm coming for this Bishop h4 Bishop f6
Wade you have some tactic I take t5 oh
he has Queen e6 I can take and play d5
you take some left to in the end
well maybe you broke f1 then just safe
and solid and now Knight 85
I think this is okay if Queenie six
maybe Bishop c4
and like I'm gonna have d5 and end in
many lines I'm not gonna play king v1 if
it's not necessary like I have to win
back my piece first actually my King is
probably safer on uncie 1 so be files
can open and he has a light square
bishop - ok so we have a weird scenario
here if like King Ron be one I could
take on e4 but what do I play maybe
rookie rookie one first
or just taken d5
let's go for this oh maybe I should have
played the other book to be one probably
would have been smarter but I just want
to make him think we're done of targets
in this position like all his pieces are
targets
I'll have very simple threat of rook to
e4 and his Knights pinned other knight
is pinned his queen is pinned and
everything is not sufficiently defended
so now I can just go I can't take oh
nice move
I guess I have to take wait am I just
losing here I might just be losing
quaint egg e6 Bishop to e6 that's not
good I'm just losing this position well
done
and might be for a while it's
unfortunate if I die because I have some
pawns
my time is terrible oh he missed 93 or
93 and I've been in the situation a few
times before where have bad position and
low on time we get the knight to f6
mmm before I guess that's not good
that's really not good
I think there's one last trick in the
position with the rook and Knight combo
so if I've learned anything
I forgive up hope oh my gosh she gave me
a free queen and I didn't take it okay
tough game he played well I was feeling
good but then might be for happened I
was feeling bad I probably should have
moved other rook to you one well I'm in
seventh place guy in first place finally
lost a game King is wide open so I'm
playing the guy in second place who
already beat me once yeah he beat me
that game where he deserts uh let's play
normal let's play qgd I should f4 okay
this is aligned in 95
this is supposed to be slightly better
for whites but very playable for black
someday I want to play c5 as I have to
bishops just want to open the position
and the light will probably come to f6
queen will come to you seven he wants to
play b4 so now it's time for c5 just
worried about 984 in the end okay if 984
9700 also his knight would hang I was
calculating some line where we trade ok
d5 but maybe b5 feeling relatively good
about this 96
yeah I like my pawns I want to play
Bishop c5 because I'm the only person
with the dark squared Bishop f2 is a
target you might play b3 or B for now
where does my queen go
it's a little bit annoying my queen has
very few squares rook e8
if you take some place like c7 I've
worked d8 let's take
taking Queen d6 or queen f8 queen f8
looks weird but I just want my work to
come to one of these squares I guess I'm
not threatening to take the Knights and
he's applying pressure but now I have 94
94 97 King h8 Bishop take p7 take on e2
maybe it's just h6 it's gonna play 94
maybe whoa
interesting if I take and take again
this might just fizzle out to a draw
I'll have roof t1 at some point I forgot
about that move so I could take I have
to take get one of these positions
I mean this is still interesting though
because this was a passed pawn rook take
g3 as possible doesn't all have Queen a
in the end so what's my Bishop d4 keep
things defended Asics will fall but have
to give up something
rook g5 probably but it has it into play
this but I think it's okay unless it's
not okay my bishop wants to come to f6
and everything will be defended some
expecting Queen b7 kingi a quintic f7
Bishop f6
and then I'll play see three
that complex position this interesting
move c3 and then c2 check
okay I have to rely on some intuition
he's running Queen d5 here that's not
good
that's really not good oh but then
Bishop e5 and f4 and c2 okay
going into this it's like an endgame
study type position just like ping pong
going back and forth this is weird
yeah this is still theory um Queeny six
maybe
kini six I have to play quickly arcing D
eight maybe
aha okay oh no I just gave up my whole
advantage he tricked me somehow that's
unfortunate
let's play Bishop b2
please pre-move Queen d4 no okay
I was rough I was really rough that's a
game to analyze so the ending was really
interesting playing another guy my new
Keon name sounds familiar
buzzer King let's play Mike I am gambit
line knight c6 and see how well-prepared
you haven't played this as tournament
yet might a key for probably not good
Bishop c5 looks nice what's going on
here you can get away with this and then
Knight g4 after d3
maybe this wasn't good at all let's play
ooh this is hanky
let's put 95 it's a simple move I think
I'm coming out okay c7 is falling that
one of these funds are falling too
if Bishop h6 Bishop d4 hmm okay I'm
happy to trade yeah now we just have
some kind of equal position try and keep
my time advantage let's play six not
lose upon I don't want to trade the
second pair of rooks or Queens maybe I
want to trade Queens straight Queens
this rook and Bishop is supposed to be
slightly better than working nights I'll
put my pawns on dark squares to
complement my bishop maybe see four we
trade you know let's trade
and now we just have kind of some equal
rook ending but I'm trying I'll play him
play g5 fix his pawns I'll play King e5
and King out for some day
Wow f4 explosive let's take and play
this and now I want to do this I have
King III I'll do this and this hmmm safe
move he's kind of insults long just
about I'm gonna play rook h3 soon mmm
we'll still work h3
I'm fighting me them one
go back ok we've done our dance I'm just
trying to confuse him
at some point I'll play c4 probably with
my rook on b4 there we go
this should be winning unless it's not
winning no this should be winning
okay I'm flagging him anyway that was
fun
back to tournaments figure out what it
feels like to win a game and buy a top
ten
hey I'm number eight and this guy's
crushing the tournament's he and crusher
is crushing the tournaments I have to
catch up to King crusher I've lost three
games so far King crusher has played
like double the amount of games that I
have so I've had some long games too
berserk war played Bishop e5
okay I'll go for e5 try and be
aggressive Lord pineapple one dollar
donation
I was unexpected
thanks Lord pineapple king h1 I think
some idea is to do this in this and this
and this attack this that's a good move
I want to play 9 f3 target two very
important center squares maybe I'll
throw in g3 even though a little bit
kind of looks wrong just have to make
sure he's not getting this diagonal ever
this is pons kind of in the way I play
Queenie one
I don't mind the position looks decent
he could have taken on a four so I was
slightly concerned about but now there's
no concerns Wow is that concerning that
might be concerning that could be very
concerning because if I take his rooks
are well placed
so I'm defending my my rook just hoping
for the best
now I'll play g4 so his pawns are in the
way of his pieces and he's up upon but
it's okay let's play h4
ideas of h5
I feel like whites just much worse here
but there's some practical chances I
want to play h5 and ooh that's a good
move King h3 then he plays h5 rook G 1
this is scary this stuff is happening I
wrote his pinned my King is tied down
likewhen g1 or queen f2 probably enough
to I want to play rook a g1 yeah I kind
of saw that coming but I'm gonna ignore
it just for the time being there's a few
different things pinned I just have to
hold on for dear life it was weird
he wants me to take but I'm not gonna
take my g5 maybe maybe here first I'm
attacking g5 mean Black has weaknesses
too
the Merc h5 is coming bishop take t5 is
coming Wow
okay he wants to meet me on h3 but he's
gonna be pinned he also wanted to play
rookie too but none of these moves work
anymore I turned around quickly
yeah I was probably in a lot of trouble
but good game okay sixth place no we're
in your first within range of King
crusher especially if he keeps losing
I'm on a streak I'm on a berserk Street
to probably have time for like what five
more games and try to try and play as
many games as possible I want to finish
third I want to finish at least third
place within 12 points I might end up
playing first place because he just
finished I don't play the first place
guy no I'm not okay I'm playing poppy
far less intimidating let's play you for
Kay's was working - that's great he's a
John Bartholomew fan team scandi going
for my classic ambit's by day six he's
prepared
we might is supposed to have a bit of
compensation in this line I think or not
that's a good move
let's place c3 attack the Queen playing
Knight c2 idea of 93
it's a weird square but also ideas a
bishop a 3 FC 5 probably Bishop a 3 if I
Castle Bishop h3 93
so I'm down the pond but we have a
interesting position not sure how much
compensation I have but I'll try and
stay up on time that's a good move
think about the night on e3 it's one of
the best offensive pieces I think ever
holds on to G to prevent something from
coming to g4 maybe I should play this
kind of for is one of the best offensive
pieces ever I want to play Bishop f1
let's restrict the Knights H to could be
a targets wow I forgot about night h3 I
forgot about my f2 pawn I have to rely
on dirty flagging this is bad so I've
gathered that a pawn and a queen this is
really bad now he's waiting for me to
resign just wait a minute longer and the
game will end that's a good move to
maybe g3 I have to avoid as many trades
oh wow
this is really bad g3 was terrible I
mean that fights as long as I can
that's first mates good game that was
rough I was brutal losing a lot of games
there goes my streak and there it goes
my chance to catch King crusher tough
treatment over a 300 player as well
forget what the turned out last time was
this might be bigger okay maybe this is
something I can beat I have to play
aggressively
okay he's playing the Carlson life I'm
ok with this let's play this I just want
to be as aggressive as possible I'm
gonna play unsound Lee but trying to win
quickly won't play this and this I don't
care about my Bishop this is this is
what it's like to be on tilt maybe I can
take this is actually very close to
winning there we go ok I need more of
those I need to just these quick wins
just get some momentum back I guess it
requires playing unsound chess which
I've been doing a lot of today just been
on the worst side of it ok 8th place I
have to pass puppey get revenge I might
play the guy in first place because he
finished
okay I'm playing the guy in first place
let's take this seriously
yeah three's a move Bishop I'm trying to
remember my theory here Bishop before I
think is a move so I played this against
naka a few times B Bishop d6 okay now we
have a structure
plates for
I like the position it has to go back
and then it's easy play for black always
play King meets c4 I want to play let's
play this first maybe b5 at some point
now see for okay going for the kill move
back here this pawn is strong let's play
c5 restrict the night
gee three good move
not happy with this but doing it anyway
really not what I wanted to do
my bishop will come to g8 maybe someday
target the king I want to play f6
because always played f6 ooh he plays up
six beat me to it
I might have five he's out tactic in me
but at least okay it's still playable
kind of let's do this and this I was
expecting Bishop take oh this is dead
lost but maybe there's hope
I have two connected passers that's not
good that was a good move who those to
my opponents now this is painful now I
lost my pawns good game he played well a
very strong player I was feeling good
until he played g3 and then things just
fell apart that's rough
I did have two connected passers they
were more weaker than they were strong
okay what's the zerk there's still time
to catch up to King crusher maybe should
be five okay we'll have a Grand Prix I
have to play like I played that previous
game where I made it in 11 moves and go
all out for the kill
yeah as aggressive as possible I don't
want to trade Queens I want to play f5
there we go I'm attacking the Knights
my pawn is pinned let's play do I want
to play Knight g5 maybe and maybe
threatening my take f7 and again I'm not
focused on sound play I'm just focused
on waiting as quickly as possible
I take f7 pawn to g6 Queen each five
ideas
probably not a good move to pre move
yeah I'm probably gonna start regretting
this very soon at first I was scared at
night f6 but then I win
after this hmm it's a good move let's
play rook here
there we go this is just for sweet now
hello doughy Urbanski how's it going
just in time
okay twenty two minutes left be nice if
you can resign okay um my goal
originally was to break 2400 close to
falling below 2300 I'm not gonna catch
keen crusher unfortunately unless some
miracle happens
yeah the top - I played both of them
they're good players
okay let's bezerk and be aggressive
ooh Kings gambit I was not expecting
I'll play the fog beer eh III right
III take whoa
Bishop e5 or Bishop d4 I'll just castle
this bishops awkward pawns attacked
probably just take it
and rookie eight will come worked a key
to the threats this is looking great
just of a piece
[Music]
always playoffs six actually let's play
this solid move now I have a sneaky
threats
I just want to win quickly rookie three
will probably come
well it's page six
the knight doesn't have too many squares
hello car Mar and hello alasa cold I'm
not really paying attention to the chat
this tournament but thanks for watching
okay back to tournament 42 points
I just want to play King crusher it's my
only goal is it gonna happen it's
happening Wow
mission accomplished let's buzzer let's
play some chess let's play let's play e5
mmm let's play the slide try and confuse
him
ooh he's confused already okay I mean
this is mainline supposed to be somewhat
equal
maybe I should take C 656 okay we have a
normal position I know he likes to
attack so goal is to not allow him to
attack that's a good move
let's play this Bishop f8 maybe g6 and
Bishop f5 and Bishop g7 let g7 first wow
d5 want to move so we're just trading it
C pawns gonna be weak I like this
position
maybe this they can think
this is a major problem the more trades
that happened the weaker the pawn
becomes I can trade okay now he's
confusing me if you don't know what to
do here let's play this attack the pawn
some point I'll play b6
maybe I should have played Queen f3
there green f3 is still possible soon
okay he's taking a lot of time which is
great Queen f3
I also have b6 ideas - wait I'm just
winning a piece there's some long
calculation rock taking you win or take
you one queen take e3 rookie eights I
lose okay that's not good
so let's play Queen f3
okay this is what I want just looking
for the kill
let's play this
I'm okay with trading put the bishop
here
and b6 and I'm waiting upon let's do
this first
okay well I beat King crusher not
catching up to him in the tournaments
but still in sixth place I'll have time
for like what two more games probably
maybe three well if I play him for three
more games and have two berserk all of
them here's a moral victory it's true
says Antonio Morales okay we'll play
this line let's play this line I usually
play the black side of this but now I'm
playing the white side I already mess up
they have messed up already
94 is typical move would 94 is terrible
oh that's really bad
so I'm losing a piece but I'll get comp
f-five maybe Queen h4 first target sum
square target all of the squares
target the pollen somehow I'm getting
compensation I don't know how it's
happening Queen d8 is now possible play
rook to you one first what are you
thinking about ideas of Bishop take g6
maybe rook f3 first Queen c5 King h1
well turkey seven
that's probably another good move I
forgot that Bishop was hanging but I
still have comp please play Queenie one
that's a much better move
this is a very weird game so far but
there's still a sliver of hope I want to
play h3 King H to unpin the rook he
wants to trade Queens clearly any Queen
any three ideas still have five ideas -
okay let's win upon
yeah this is gonna be tough and a four
let's do a four I mean it's a passed
pawn but it's only passed pawn on the
board passed pawns must be pushed
this is really bad though I'm trying my
best place III mmm let's play this first
I do have some king power
this isn't good it's really not good
please take my rook funny idea
please take my rook no he's not taking
my rook want him to take the rook that
wouldn't even be stalemate but okay now
I need to win the pawn I resign I was
Rafi I tried so nature of bizarre King
it's tough it's easy to blunder it's
also the nature of playing almost two
hours of chess I'm playing this guy
again okay let's try and be solid this
slide let's play just play a normal
London
I feel like this is probably some title
player who's playing anonymously clearly
a strong player I mean it could just
could be carlson who knows that would be
funny though
I don't think Carlson is on reddit too
often g4 maybe let's play this the
thought of this being Carlson makes me
really nervous now a deep breath
deep breaths actually the position is
fine my time is okay
maybe my night will come - okay let's
play this first I kept a 5 in some day
96
you wants to play f5 that's really
annoying actually
try and trade nights wait why would I
pre move Queen take a strong move wait a
minute
or it's not a blunder oh you can take
with Queen
so maybe this stay alive it was very
ugly position
getting some counterplay this pawn
should fall hmm maybe this first so I'll
have rook g7 with tempo and then b6 b7
b8 that's the plan I'm down the pond but
number of pawns don't matter this tricky
tactic so okay let's just went up on
back because B Sixers Bishop d6
what do I do
oh man wait this is really bad
time situation take counterplay nice
tactic that's bad
I steal me myself Bishop c3 please oh
that's not even okay tough game
I feel like I had chances there but
maybe I didn't I probably did it felt
like a good now felt like a good
position somewhere but he got counter
play yeah it's it's probably very
unlikely Carlsen see when that count was
created oh he played a marathon okay oh
he's played a lot Wow
I might have one more game to get in no
it's done tournament is over I'll
probably end in sixth place
well those interesting events I had some
tough games I deserved a lot lost a lot
of rating points lost like 80 points
since the beginning of the tournament
I'd be curious to analyze the last game
that was this one right yeah at least
just the end game because I was feeling
good around here
rook b3 was a good move though and I
wanted to play b6 but Bishop d6 is such
a strong response
so maybe what I should have done I
should have played b6 first just a
matter of move order at b6 if he 3 then
here nothing's still Bishop d6 oh but
then I win because I I have Bishop g3 in
the very end and that should yeah yeah
just an easy winner so if I played b6
maybe Bishop no Bishop c5 still work g7
so I have a feeling this is winning now
let's check with stockfish no it's
losing bishop
well there's bunch of good move for
black Bishop c5 or g7 and the tournament
is finished
so congratulations born of good and void
Isis something so is finishing in third
well good job everyone how many people
watching the stream also played the
tournament because I would be curious or
did you just like you don't like blitz
so you just like to watch because I know
there's some people they were saying
they were gonna play and watch at the
same time but yeah this was a tough
performance or tough tough results I
played the first rider tournament last
month but I only played half of it so I
had to go in the middle
we're playing the full thing it's not
easy it takes endurance so it's been two
hours I'm getting challenges now I don't
think I want to play for chess so
it's already been a long day so
yeah I have things to do today
so thanks everyone for watching I
appreciate all the the supports I
apologize if my games were overly
graphic but that's what happens
sometimes so I'm gonna end it there I
might read someone so stay around for a
few moments but in the meantime I will
see you guys in the future bye